[Music]
me neither
includes the [__] I hate you
yeah hey hey hey merch all hacks all
hacks
I can't deny that
hey you know if you kick Crowder in the
dick his tongue comes it still comes out
you know Crowder you know Crowder
reclines right if you okay you know it's
funny if you uh if you kick the quarter
in the face he bites off Crowder's dick
hey wait this isn't Jeremy boring then
who did I spend two hours in a hot tub
with
the quartering should change his name to
Jeremy boring
yeah
you know what say what you will about
Stephen Crowder he gives you boys life
this really does
I don't really know if it's Stephen
Crowder so much as the suffering of you
know Mercy Royce now I feel bad for my
Benihana joke
should I know I know
look at it
oh [__] my favorite part of that Crowder
video is when he literally says and this
is literally these kids were born what
18 months ago and he had like a health
scare right before his kids were born
and like you know you'd think he'd have
some perspective my favorite quote from
Crowder this whole week has been I
haven't been happy in a long time yeah
because your closet I hope you kids see
this video someday you [__] jack off
well I haven't been happy for a long
time yeah Merce showed me the picture of
you kissing your wife so
so this is um
here we go
you ready
now can I point out the first thing the
shirt ready the shirt not the shirt oh
the fact that this is titled I didn't
want to have to do this and he's
grinning from ear to ear yeah you look
real hesitant
a lot of things that are about that
we're about to see here so we played the
the Jeremy boring video yesterday
um
of the counter offer when did we watch
quartering no
not Jeremy the boring just Jeremy boring
Jeremy the boring
me more veteran
House of hack hey Royce can I just ask a
question before you do this breaker of
algorithms hey Royce
why would Stephen Crowder put a talk boy
on his desk
oh cause he's about to talk boy I hate
you all right here you go
um Stephen decided the normal thing to
do in contract negotiations
is to go scorched earth right away to
secretly record even renegotiate not
even try one renegotiation just scorched
Earth destroy your enemies record secret
conversations blackmail extortion how
was your trip to Hawaii a mosquito bit
me so I nuked the whole [__] Island
it's done now I was saying on night wave
last night like when we when we were
working out the thing with Rumble right
yeah there was one or two things that we
weren't like thrilled about the wording
of but you just you just shoot them an
email and you go hey this third line
here can we change that to say this oh
yeah it's no probable we'll send you
another copy of it all right cool you
sent it back you with red lines through
the things you want removed or edited
and then they work with you normally but
it's not only that doxed siraj's family
yeah yeah me too the problem is there's
so many muhammads it's still really hard
to find him
I mean yeah I just we realized we I
doxed this whole family and we realized
that they're they're Muslims and they're
not [__] [__] he's like every
Millennial Zoomer right so really they
just said we have your address and they
said okay
all right uh here we go
they don't get deals that
wait uh that's his big reveal that's not
none of that's really that's a nothing
burger and the way you say again I'm not
trying to carry water for daily wire but
I think Jeremy boring is being and by
the way not to be confused with the
quartering
um he's simply like being kind of funny
about it but it's like yeah look if they
don't have a big brand and we sign them
like yeah that'd be wage slaves for a
little while while they grow their brand
here
it's a problem
[Applause]
God bless the talk boy those things are
worth like five thousand dollars now
it's an expensive gag
um so didn't want to have to do this but
you seem very gleeful about something
for a man who didn't want to do this
yeah as Marsh pointed out a guy who
already bought the URL
daily wire out of themselves you should
have you should have like the uh the
vibe of somebody who just had to go out
and kill a raccoon in your backyard or
something like that should be the vibe
you're giving off like well I didn't
want to have to do that that was yeah
but it had to be done you know you're
burning a long time business [__]
like partner basically and like one like
two of your like best friends in media
like longest time friends in media you
should be acting like you like shot your
dog at least that's what I mean you
should have the demeanor of somebody who
just had their pet put to sleep yeah
like not like you know like a young like
not like a puppy but like at least like
an old dog like [__] it Sage [__] said
uh it's five dollars on Rumble uh this
sandwich never even did salary
negotiations for a real job and it shows
yeah I mean has been pointed out I think
for the most part his dad
um
was the one that does most of the
business stuff for him you know what I
mean
very very quickly and sure enough
if you see all of the people who who
work there
um some of whom I have relationships
with they immediately tried to make this
all about money yeah but Crowder here's
the thing is though let me let me let me
give you a little bit of new in from
something threaded as I mentioned here
and this is verified
Crowder didn't Redline a con like you
know which I mentioned earlier basically
you know added stuffs out of the
contract back and forth different
revisions nobody ever signs the first
revision of any contract if you do
you're [__] right you're literally
[__] so instead of going back and
doing that Crowder did not complain
about the wording and the contract
Crowder wanted
30 million dollars a year
instead of the 50 million five yeah
exactly well good no it was 50 million
over over a year right instead of those
over four years so I've been yeah so he
wanted a lot more money right he wanted
basically almost double right
um he wanted 30 million that's where it
broke down it's he wanted more money he
never at least unless
he has to prove otherwise he never
brought up that it had anything to do
with the smaller creators and [__] like
that but but that it sounds like he set
him up it sounds like that set him up
that's that's what he gets to in this
video right so he even admits that he
called one last time and recorded it
right so that he could get this stuff on
tape
then he when he called the last time
knew he was recording it then he was
like but what about the smaller creators
like he knew what he was doing right
right he knew what he was doing he was
positioning himself to do this he knew
he was going to release this tape yeah
he always was yeah I guess you're right
here's the problem there are a few
problems and I'll go through with some
receipts
um everything that was said about
negotiations how they transpired beyond
the numerical value which is true and
I'll get to everything else is untrue
I I don't really want to get into that
it's completely irrelevant here's why
not but why not when Jeremy boring when
Jeremy boring replied to you again not
the quartering
um he [__] he okay let's fix this
this is it quartering is boring Jeremy
so when Jeremy boring responded to you
sir it was a 53 minute long video where
he had the entire contract in front of
him and he went through it line for line
he was calm he was unemotional and he
stated the facts you're the one who's
like fidgeting a lot you're all at or
all that of your [__] face and you're
secretly recording people like you're
Richard Nixon like in no way are you the
good guy here well that's not fair
that's not fair and then when he's like
oh they're lying about me but I don't
want to get involved but that's not fair
because when Richard Richard Nixon was
Richard Nixon was secretly recording
people he was very popular
that is true so there is there's a
little bit of a difference there you
know
they've landed his Gerald Ford yes no no
it's his uh what's the other one uh
Henry Kissinger oh yeah
going back to the 20-something minute
video 30 minute video 25 minute video
you've never heard me say or write
anywhere online anything funny never
once have you ever heard me do anything
funny say what you will about the man at
least he's consistent
these offers weren't paying enough money
why because it's not about the money but
it is you ask for more you asked for
more of it
and they said the whole his whole
contention was
that if [__] if if I get banned off
of YouTube or if I get a strike on one
of these big Tech platforms
they reduce the money that's yeah
that was his whole [__] complaint
yeah if you reduce the money yeah but
but but but but he's trying to Pivot it
he's trying to Pivot it
into being like but I'm not doing that
for me because I could take the hit but
these smaller creators they can't and
then on top of this dude on top of this
[__] he wants to sit here and cry and go
oh if I get kicked off of YouTube or
some [__] you're already following the
[__] rules of YouTube you haven't
gotten kicked off you haven't [__]
ever broken TOS the [__] that they
didn't retroactively hit you with like
so you're complaining about daily wire
holding you to the terms and conditions
of YouTube when you already [__] do
that yourself but here's my thing
Crowder
stop being a homo you could have just
said no to the offer you can't he's got
engaging I know take 230 to take your
350 000 person plus mailing list
and do your own thing I'm not defending
the daily wire I want to be clear here I
hate the daily wire okay I think the
daily wire is filled with a bunch of
establishment piece of [__] Rhino hacks
up and down top to bottom that's what I
think
I'm sure there's probably a couple good
people there but for the most part
everything I've ever seen is your
typical Rhino [__] shitty talking
points but my thing is here is people
taking sides on this my thing thing is
like immerse it's got to be nice and I
saw you tweeted something out about it
merge but isn't it nice to see now
people this a lot of a lot of people
that criticized us using our talking
points to attack one another it's
beautiful it's so funny it's so funny to
see this it's like go [__] you guys all
all of you are retards
yeah have you heard of that guy he's bad
it's kind of unreal to me that the only
thing these people can still talk about
is the money the conversation was about
it
[Applause]
so then if it's not about the money how
come every time's YouTube demonetizes
you you [__] panicked and then you
had a call to arms and then start
pushing your mug Club that's ever every
time he panicked and if it's not about
the money then why do you oh so much
stuff I want to say why do you I mean
good with stuff I can't say Twinkle Toes
I know I got it I got it I got it I
could do this here comes why do you now
have a documented a documented history
of underpaying your staff
and then
true or not I don't know but there's a
little bird out there talking about that
when you're released if you want that
better severance package they make you
sign an extra NDA not just a regular one
but an extra one where you can't talk
about anything
so mister I just want freedom Mr all I
want is this you are one of the
stingiest people in the world you
underpay your employees the benefits
[__] [__]
you know and also I want to point out
that not gay Jared made it clear and I
don't blame him because he tweeted out
you know saying like I left Crowder
under I left ladder with Crowder because
I wanted to leave with a two-week notice
no one made me leave but he said why I
left is my own personal decision so
pervatism the movement in big Tech okay
cool Crowder then if it's not about the
money then why don't you take the 50
million dollars and spread it out to
smaller content creators that are trying
to make it
oh God no gross oh no okay just making
sure
keep talking about money I'm talking
about a country I'm
ew here it is there it is here it is
here it is here it is my favorite part
it's about the movement price ew it's
about our it's about our nation that he
wasn't born talking about a movement I'm
talking about making a difference it's
not about the money and Jeremy and the
daily wire know that how do I know they
know that because after
according to what he said you know I
walked away from the offer I did Place
one more call
to the Daily wire and I made it very
very clear
that it wasn't about money that was not
the topic of conversation there was Zero
as they've tried to portray this
miscommunication
it was one last call where the only
thing that I asked for my only demand
was their word and not even for me
but for other people coming up facing
these kinds of contracts let's say it's
a kid who comes in with 500 000 YouTube
subscribers or something like they're a
hundred thousand let's say some other
kid you're paying you're paying six
figures to come in and do it there's
there's not the penalty of the
demonetization or if they're removed
from iTunes Apple
YouTube
here's something else
he has no dirt it's literally him being
transparent I am not defending daily
wire I'm we're about to play Adventure
and that contract does suck but that
being said then don't take it it's a
shitty it's a shitty contract don't take
the shitty couple you think the
differences between this is and this is
why Marsh and I are so different when it
comes to this is that we already went
into this knowing daily wire was [__]
piece of [__] garbage that exploit their
employees so you're not I'm not do we're
not shocked the contract by the way is
exactly what I would think a slimy Ben
Shapiro and Jeremy boring contract would
look like was was anybody Mercer were
you shocked by the content of that
contract because I would never sign with
the daily wire I think you're stupid if
you do
I'm sorry let me be clear here for 50
million dollars I will sign with the
thinning wire but over four years over
four years wow even so so I don't want
to be Ben Shapiro Shabbos [__] for longer
than one year fair enough even Beyond it
being the daily wire there was nothing
in that contract that wasn't
part and parcel of your typical
entertain your typical first draft
entertainment contract like that look
that read like any [__] record deal
any [__] like new like it that was
standard it's just like I said just do
what me and Royce do and go hey we
didn't like you know what is it
paragraph three you know section c I
didn't like this park we changed the
wording that's all and they'll say yes
or they'll say no and by the way what
happened by the way by the way
trust me if because there's some new
people coming in here and I think a lot
of people that might be watching don't
know the old lore with also Ben Shapiro
or Crowder
they're both horrible nobody here is in
any way different because we're about to
play a Ben Shapiro video where he looks
just as bad I'm my opinion have you seen
the Ben Shapiro one where he looks just
as bad as Crowder so they both they're
both pieces of [__] the problem is is
yes I do agree
I do agree that daily wire pretends
we're anti-big Tech but they run their
business exactly like big Tech 100 I
also know that latter were Crowder the
[__] a bunch of people that work at
ladder of crowd or a bunch of [__]
rhinos and a bunch of pro-ukraine
[__] [__] that you also pretend
there aren't that don't work there but
you really don't care also and I also
know that I think Daddy is probably
letting you [__] sink or swim for the
first time by yourself and you
completely panicking and don't know what
you're doing Stephen you don't know what
you're doing Mercer and I might not make
50 million dollars but we know what a
scared trial looks like and this is what
a scared child looks like
yeah my other favorite part of this too
is when he's when he starts telling
Jeremy and the tape he goes uh you know
oh well you're just you're going to
charge these people and you're gonna do
this and he's like yeah he's like well
then change your business model excuse
me guy who's at the job interview you
know I like I couldn't just go into some
like Fortune 500 company
and be like I want you to pay me five
million dollars a year to be a middling
employee and when they go we're not
paying you that go well then maybe you
need to change your business model broke
boy like you're the one asking for a job
you're the one who needs daily wires
money to scale your business up it's not
the other way around so how are you
going to go in beg for money in a
contract and then also tell them well
your business model is [__] gates up
above says the amount of people who
believe Crowder about the movement is
hilarious they don't know how how much
of hip or piece of shitty is if daily
wire offered 150 million he would be all
over that deal absolutely we're used to
it by now though yeah I it's so [__]
disingenuous because like Crowder knows
how this [__] Works he's not a [__]
idiot this is so [__] [__]
they're paying you for your YouTube
channel if your YouTube channel gets
struck it's worth less they're
protecting their investment if you don't
want that to be the case then go in and
say hey I don't want to sell the rights
to my YouTube channel take that off but
you're not gonna do that Stephen because
then they would lower the fee but but
it's not only but but he does a pro
little project Veritas a little attack
is what he tried to do right by secretly
recording him and he got nothing because
I love what he's saying right now it's
like oh it's it's about it's about it's
not about to about my country it's right
I tweeted this earlier today but like
hey guys
High smaller but yes still content
creator here let me explain something to
you because I think it's super important
you guys go none of us are going to save
the country none of us are going to fix
anything we're not part of any movement
you know what we are we are the [__]
band playing as the USS American
experiment sinks to the bottom of the
ocean because we want people to have
some [__] laughs that's what we are
if you go into life knowing your place
and knowing what you're part of it is
and and you'll be a much happier person
than thinking you're faking you're some
sort of [__] Freedom Fighter when
you're now some sort of [__]
millionaire millionaire hack who
couldn't make anybody laugh and lured a
bunch of Boomers with your shitty made
mugs
it's ridiculous accurate yeah it's what
this is this what this is merch and I
always want never merch and I have never
gone into this Pretend We're going to
change the world or think we're gonna
[__] change anything if anything
we're probably making it worse I'm being
fair but that being said all we want to
do is make you [__] laugh and that's
pretty much what this is you know don't
try to be more than you are okay because
explain to me what movements you're
doing other than bowels when you're
doing a [__] Nirvana parody Or
Another kiss parody or or some other
dumb ass what are you doing Gilbert
Godfrey Bernie Sanders Impressions what
how are you helping huh what have you
done changing people's minds hey I hate
to break the news to you this goes to
Crowder and to Ben Shapiro owning 19
year olds would change your mind
segments or little debates nobody cares
about that anymore kids are [__]
literally [__] they're right now
they think if they cut their dicks off
they could be girls so owning them with
facts and logic isn't that big of a deal
and Crowder has never ever made me laugh
can I ask you something if if you saw me
getting into a heated lengthy argument
with a college age person
would your response be anything other
than dude what is wrong with you I mean
now what I would say is like what a
colossal waste of your time what are you
doing here's what I would say you [__]
because if I'm starting with a favor it
would be like did you [__] her be like
yeah I just left my cigarettes up there
and she won't get them for me now so
[__]
it'll be one of those are you [__]
her just like I'll tell you in the car
stop by the 7-Eleven I'm gonna have to
buy New York 7-Eleven please thank you
to be fair dude we all stood in a bar
and watched you argue with a woman with
the brain age of a [__] oh my God but
she wouldn't leave me alone yeah well
it's not like I was like oh I'm gonna
fight this yeah you really were trying
to get away it was funny it was
prescription drugs do that bud yeah bud
I was also very measured I was
painstakingly clear no you were a little
too measured you were too little little
too psychotic registering domains to to
fight your friends and calling them a
month later to uh to record the Canadian
manufacturer controversy and get people
to sign up for your Mud Club because
that's all this is the Canadian
psychopath ladies and gentlemen is back
he's not back he never left he just went
into hiding for a while but here he is
he's back and he's doing the [__]
weird crazy things look I don't give a
[__] if these people eat themselves I
think it's [__] hilarious this is
some of the best stuff I was actually
joking with with dick Masterson's on
Twitter because he was like what's going
on and I was like I know right he go he
was like everyone is looking worse in
this and that's true at the end of this
whole thing nobody looks better
everybody and I think it's hilarious you
know what Marissa Central we look better
but none of them look better you know
yeah but just like they look worse and
we look better and nobody cares about
either but no you're right but you got
to love these people that always [__] on
these smaller content creators and this
and that are now basically setting up
for a killstream segment Crowder versus
Shapiro because what's what's different
that's real sweet of that yeah he should
though Ralph really should be like hey
Anna's Crowder Shapiro come on the kills
let's go imagine I [__] Ben Shapiro
crowd are calling each other [__] on
cozy and calling each other the n-word
oh [__] anything's better than listen to
this and Destiny's [__] debate
somebody again yeah we gotta did you
read Ben's timeline yeah well I actually
I was I mean yeah yes what I was going
to do was I also had Ben Shapiro's uh
video response oh yes oh I didn't yeah
the video response covers a lot of his
timelines okay so this will be a good
way to do that social Observer with ten
dollars Crowder registered stop bitcon
on the 12th and announced that he was
leaving The Blaze on the 15th sounds
like the rift was land out of course
yeah
well folks I'm sure many of you have
seen the controversy that has broken out
between I would say our former friend
Stephen Crowder and those of us here at
the daily wire and it makes me sick too
my stomach no it doesn't you have no
feelings you listen here baby genius let
me [__] explain something to you all
right
you know what you have to hold on your
head like you're [__] yamako for the
rest of your life that Alex Jones was
100 right about the vaccine and you were
100 wrong and no no owning a bunch of 19
year olds is ever going to fix that bud
Nothing's Gonna fix it you have to own
that forever like a yellow star
Ben Shapiro strikes me as the kind of
guy that shows up to watch his children
be born and the minute the baby pops out
he goes well all right then good job no
no just goes home as soon as you confirm
that they're circumcised then he leaves
he's got to confirm that that's very
important he walks into the birthing
room sees his wife's vagina goes oh and
then leaves yeah yak yak apparently she
can get wet uh Sage [__] yes I'm
highly I'm highly autistic and it took
some finesse but I got chat GPT with
some fine-grained wording to make Steven
Crowder come out as a homosexual Mercy's
DMS have the screenshot business partner
Jeremy boring has made him sick to his
stomach as well because we had always
considered Stephen A friend I was Steve
are you
did you really consider him a friend
because that was your first mistake you
[__] even we knew you guys were all
backstabbing sociopaths I just thought
it was going to go the other way first I
thought it was going to be correct Marsh
would you not agree that if you were to
say who's going to stab who in the back
first I honestly thought I was going to
be Shapiro doing it to uh to uh to
Stephen first
evidence first lawyer I helped negotiate
his contract with Fox News going all the
way back it's got oh wow you already
hear him taking credit for Crowder's
career I helped negotiate his contract
for Fox News and be at least over a
decade and um and Steven I had always
been very friendly I know Jeremy was
even friendlier with Stephen had
counseled him in very rough times I had
personally attempted to intervene when
Stephen was demonetized in June 2019 on
YouTube I actually sounded off so loudly
that the people at YouTube reached out
to me and Susan watch Kiki got the head
of YouTube got on the phone with me and
I reamed her out over demonetizing
Stephen must be nice to be able to get
it oh my God Marsh you took the words
right out of my mouth so you're telling
me the person who has a direct line of
Susan wojinski is not the same as big
Tech
you mean the person who YouTube reached
out because they want to keep happy but
everybody else gets to monetize they
don't care you're telling me that you
guys aren't big con of course you are
he's not wrong the difference is is that
Crowder used to be part of it until the
paycheck it wasn't right no more
yeah that look the thing is is that
Crowder is not wrong about you he's just
wrong about himself yes like it's not
that Crowder thinks you're the bad guy
that he's wrong he said he thinks he's
the good guy hey you know what they say
a hack clock is right twice a day
and um I hope it made a difference you
know look I think that that Stephen is
an incredibly talented comedian I
that's like probably the biggest lie in
this whole video
disgusting dinner me like that dinner
with friends dinner alone
watching TV alone thing also think that
what he is doing to my friend Jeremy
boring right now is one of the most
disgusting things I have ever seen in
politics it really is one of the ugliest
things I've ever seen
hold on he's Jewish
so yes disclosing contract agreements
would be the most disgusting thing you
do to a Jewish man like Ben Shapiro that
is like breaking one of one of the rules
of acquisition of your Ferengi you don't
do it I was going to say one of the
ugliest things in politics was Linda
Tripp's face yeah that's true that's
that's true
in order to understand what's happening
I think you have to understand a couple
of things so for those who missed the
story basically Jewish and my wife's a
doctor
okay okay can I can I give some credit
to Tech Master send for this tweet sure
Crowder turned down 50 million dollar
offer from the daily wire out of
principle the principle of it being not
being enough money
that's pretty [__] funny
we offered Steven in a term sheet a
non-binding term sheet a non-binding
term sheet is exactly what it sounds
like it is a list of terms for a
proposed negotiation for a contract and
the negotiation happens then you come to
a final contract that is what a
non-binding term sheet is his agent had
solicited us to make him an offer this
is when he was in his closing days with
the Blazing so okay so that is actually
a lie now we got to call him out right
his uh apparently from what you what is
verifiable Crowder's agent is not the
one
that reached out
to daily wire to make an offer daily
wire reached out to him when he left the
blaze so that is what I'm hearing and
I'm not again I want to be make sure
that because I'm not going to let this
little [__] worm
get away with with these little lies
either because what I'm hearing they
reach and by the way
there's you could say that that doesn't
make you look bad you should if you're
the daily wire right you're me you're a
right a right wing I I think that he's
afraid of legal ramifications of like
contract tampering approaching somebody
while they're still under contract with
somebody else even if that contract's
almost up yeah there might have been
some language that Ben might be covering
his ass by being like hey we didn't you
know kind of like with WWE and aw we're
getting into that like with each other
with the contract maybe it was like hey
we didn't send any feelers out they came
to us
uh and I do agree with batty girl
Crowder is no different than daily wire
the only thing is the normies are
learning the game yeah yeah that's true
I would also argue that I you know
that's a really good point I do think
that a lot of people that were
there's a lot of people in 2016 they
were just like yeah these guys are great
are becoming like us Marsh a little more
a little older a little more grizzled
like you saw Robbie Goodwin's tweet
no uh Robbie Goodwin tweeted out this
Crowder versus Shapiro thing is like
King Kong versus Godzilla for dudes who
were bow ties in high school
I retweeted it it was [__] really
funny that's a good one right yeah how's
it going right
so we sent him over a non-binding term
sheet for 50 million dollars over the
course of four years with an additional
two-year option at 25 million dollars
that is as it sounds like a lot of money
but we thought that Steven is worth it
because Steven is again an incredibly
talented guy with a very very large
following you have more the latter than
the former huh it wouldn't matter if he
was talented all that mattered is that
email list as I keep pointing out and um
all I wanted if you want to hear the
actual terms of the term sheet all you
have to do is go to the description on
this particular video or head on over to
YouTube and you can see my business
partner Jeremy boring read the terms
word for word
Steven's original video in which he
attacked us so this week this week
Steven attacked Jeremy boring and
attacked the daily wire and suggested
that we had essentially offered him a an
enslavement contract that would have
robbed him of all of his freedom and
made him subject to the whims of big
Tech and all the rest of this kind of
[__] and
oh wow hold on a second icy boy is angry
empty yeah don't want to get demonetized
yeah God forbid it's really funny that
he's talking about how it wouldn't it
was [__] that it would make him
behold into big Tech while he's bleeping
out [__] for big Tech to stay
monetize on YouTube
stay monetized on YouTube that's why he
did it yeah oh that's so great that's so
[__] great you can't bro you can't
make half of this [__] up these people
by the way somebody and then some people
the people in the chat like a couple
people on the chat like nobody watches
even cares about Chrono Shapiro I'm very
sorry but merch and I have been held
down by these [__] retards for very
very long and we became successful in
spite of these [__] yeah this is our
time our touchdown dance and we're gonna
keep doing it
and um it's just not true Jeremy unlike
Stephen read the entire text of the term
sheet on the air and goes through it
piece by piece and explains exactly how
it works and in short all the contract
says is we are offering you this
gigantic sum of money and if you start
to lose money for the company and for
yourself because you lose YouTube for
example and we both lose money so you
lose some money because this is
typically how contracts work on this
show well I think the problem with these
contracts is to [__] on these [__]
the problem with these contracts is
that
you can't in the one breath
say that you oh Billy wire fights a big
Tech big Tech censors us this and that
but also have this direct phone number
to Susan wijicki first off let's start
with that but secondly then say well yes
even though we're fighting big Tech part
of our money and your money is on this
company that we talked that about
YouTube which we talk [__] about what
you should do if you're fighting big
Tech if it wasn't all about the money if
it was actually making an alternative
platform is remove YouTube from the pay
structure for both people let them keep
their channel right I'm not saying make
them their Channel go away let them keep
their Channel but do not reward them nor
penalize them for Content they do on
their YouTube right but they don't want
to do that because at the end of the day
how can you say any of these people
Crowder or Ben Shapiro say they want to
fight big Tech when they're so beholden
to their F to the numbers literally how
can you say you want to fight YouTube
when like a large percentage of your
income at Daily wire and louder with
Crowder comes from from YouTube
you know well not only that [__] left
YouTube how's that remember when Stephen
pretended to be a [__] hero and I'm
gonna Sue big Tech and then he took a
[__] sellers oh man we're gonna take
him to court we're gonna get him to open
up their books and then they offered him
a quiet settlement and he just took it
no yeah everything he does is a [__]
lie yeah
and the problem is now you're making me
choose well not me I'm not choosing this
[__] both but a lot of people
conservatives are fighting to choose
between
the guy the guy the guy the guy the guy
the guy the guy who
secretly secretly records uh at the best
friends at the worst people he's doing
business with secretly records uh
business contract meetings underpays his
employees makes him sign ndas or do you
want to side with the guy who called you
an idiot if you didn't get the vaccine
and is one of the biggest rhinos walking
around today who do you pick who's the
good guy here both of them suck the
quicker you guys all figure out that
these people are a bunch of grifters and
no one's gonna [__] save you the
better you're gonna feel about
yourselves these guys aren't virtuous
these guys do not believe what they are
saying they've never have
wait Royce are you saying that this guy
who in the last three minutes has said
the word money 25 plus times doesn't
care about me yeah
uh
uh Fedora says you so YouTube is just
advertising for him he doesn't make
money off of it shut up
shut up
yes he does stop it Do not sit there and
buy that they make money off of YouTube
all right because they do because if
they didn't they would leave YouTube go
see hey we're live only on Rumble right
now we're not live on YouTube crowd will
be live on Rumble when YouTube doesn't
let him [__] put your money literally
where your mouth is you won't do it none
of these people ever [__] do it yeah
he's already tweeting about Rumble now
like he's yeah he's cool I don't care he
could come over here come hang out but
now you're the new kid
so uh you gotta go [__] uh do our
laundry
and you gotta buy us lunch every day
that's how it works he has to rack the
weights you gotta rack the weights you
know what they're doing my bags yes you
got to carry the bags you got to rack
the weights you got to get us the
Gatorade you're basically 1994 Triple H
let's [__] go for 95 Triple H
go for example if I lose advertisers and
the revenue of the show goes down then I
lose Revenue personally because the
revenue of the show has gone down so
again if you want the details the
legalistic details no no we know the
legal is the details Ben we don't need
to be [__] Super Genius to understand
why you have it in the contract I get it
I just don't think that you on the one
hand should be say you're fighting big
Tech but also incorporate YouTube into
your contracts right
and I don't want Crowder to say that
YouTube doesn't matter and then every
time he gets demonetized he [__]
literally throws a conniption on air and
cries about it so if YouTube doesn't
matter then it doesn't [__] matter by
the way guys did you know that we got
another strike on YouTube and I forgot
to completely mention it for old stuff
because that's how little I [__] care
about it now
because wow yeah yeah that's right I was
like yeah remember we didn't even
mention it because we didn't even care
we're like who cares so nice who gives a
[__] not having to worry about it we
don't care about it
Tales of all this you can check out
Jeremy's video it is absolutely
comprehensive and irrefutable because
again it reveals I've never seen anybody
else do this he reveals literally the
entirety of the of the what was supposed
to be confidential term sheet that
Stephen decided to partially leak for
his own benefit and this is the part
that's really ugly okay so the part
that's really ugly is the Betrayal of
friendship so
you thought you were friends with
someone you were negotiating a 50
million dollar contract with you he's
lying by the way he doesn't mean that
he's doing this for you know the
the typical cry bully things both both
of these guys are doing crybably things
by the way you know that right that's
what this is both of them are doing it
to each other
Ben started out with IHOP contain his
contracts fat guys guys facts facts I
helped Crowder get his job on Fox he
owes me his life I considered his
friends he's the best person in the
world I mean I always rejected all his
dinner invites but we were friends okay
folks we were real friends and like
friends real friends we actually like
you know make a list of everything good
we ever did for you yeah
yeah exactly that's my point it's like
and we always get to him and we offer
him a lot of money it was so much money
both of you look [__] horrible all of
you look horrible in this right now
Crowder's the idiot number one because
this little thing he's doing is not
going to make him any new fans it's not
and this is definitely not going to make
daily wiring any new fans but I don't
[__] care
I don't [__] care because these
people need to eat each other all of
these people just become big Tech and
the same [__] version of it how many
times has Ben Shapiro we saw the
off-camera stuff Ben Shapiro talking
about I don't want to be canceled it's
all about money buddy I get it
last night
Stephen Crowder in response to Jeremy
reading the entire term sheet and saying
somehow Stephen misconstrued this and is
using this to attack us and and launch a
website called stop big con as though we
are in the pocket of big Tech you are
you just said you had a conversation
with the person who runs YouTube on the
phone to advocate
I can't do that
no you you literally put it in your
contract that that if if the money
the from YouTube goes away then they
like you pin what are you talking about
this is [__] kids kids you're just
both awful that's exactly what this
breaks down to right these people are
all [__] awful they're both pieces of
[__] we are in the pocket of big Tech we
who have invested literally tens of
millions of dollars building
alternatives to Big Tech we who put up
people like Matt Walsh and Candace Owens
and Mike we've been attacked by Facebook
and have been attacked they've been
attacked on Facebook even though daily
wire is absolutely just shows up even
when you don't subscribe to them on
Facebook
act in the Legacy Media all the time and
who are routinely demonetized wait yes
nailed it we were in the pocket of big
Tech this was Steven's line of attack
and supposedly this line of attack came
from that term sheet right the idea was
that the term sheet was doing the work
of big Tech because the term sheet
suggested that if he got demonetized
from YouTube and we both lost money that
he would also lose money
what he apparently wanted us to do was
continue to pay him extraordinary sums
of money even if the show was losing
money which is called a charity it is
not no Ben this is again ah
bro listening to two people and both of
them being wrong simultaneously is
hilarious right it's great this is
[__] amazing to see now Ben no no no
no no no no you cannot be fighting big
Tech and also rely on your income from
Big Tech you cannot have both right
like how can you
Ben is the same guy that'll be like if
you hate capitalism so much why do you
have an iPhone okay Ben if you hate big
Tech so much why are you on YouTube
because it's all a [__] charade
I had one more person's take that I did
want to play
I I oh this [__] guy Mike white guys
man here you go even Crowder daily wire
50 million dollar Feud has escalated the
Rubicon has been crossed and there's no
turning back now for Stephen Crowder if
you missed my previous video please
watch that first before sounding off in
the comments because I covered a lot of
this in detail there there's some I I
get the gist nah loud screaming girl
mustache new development so we will
continue oh my God I was thinking the
same thing man it looks like when they
it looks like when they CGI removed
Henry cavill's mustache it is shiny
there should be one there
he does look like he would be better
with a mustache he has Kevin Nash lip
hey Mark Dice a girl mustache yeah he's
so gorgeous so gorgeous in the lips this
evolves better than Kevin Nash the
biggest players in conservative Media or
at least in the new conservative media
and you know what fun fact about Mark
Dice you won't job for anybody either
good for him
conflicting business models and I have
to be honest it's a very shady behavior
on the part of Stephen Crowder and if
you've been watching my channel for any
amount of time you know that I think
Stephen Crowder is an unmitigated [__]
released excerpts of a secretly recorded
phone call that he had with the CEO of
the daily wire the co-ceo Jeremy boring
supposedly showing the receipts the
proof that he had that they were in bed
with big Tech and we'll get into hell
unethical it is to secret record
conversations with your supposed friends
that you've known for 10 years in a
moment but Steven's trying to paint this
as if he was just trying to look out for
little YouTubers who are up and coming
and might get ensnared this next
generation of YouTubers in these guys
David Crowder has never done anything
for smaller YouTubers I I I'm loving me
some Mark Dice right now yeah he's 100 I
ever don't I always know yeah this is a
[__] base take so far yeah so far so
good
well I mean I've liked them ever since
the Dave Rubin thing
yes you're renting you're renting a womb
remember that oh
contracts at places like the daily wire
not even so mad at him yeah and we were
just cheering him on
but for other people coming up facing
these kinds of contracts let's say it's
a kid who comes in with 500 000 YouTube
subscribers or something like they're a
hundred thousand let's say some other
kid you're paying you're paying six
figures to come in and do it there's
what's with the succession with penalty
of the demonetization or if they're
removed from iTunes Apple
YouTube yeah
wow you mean when they lose their
audience and then the ad reads aren't
being heard on those platforms the
advertisers aren't going to pay the
daily wire so the
okay Mark Daily wires I'm enjoying this
we have the hosts wow well what a
surprise next Crowder will get the daily
wire on tape admitting that water is wet
his other point is that the daily wire
will supposedly own your content if you
sign up with them and he was worried
about them stealing his content or
taking ownership of it and then getting
stuck in this terrible contract that you
then own
well I own parts of it I don't own it
they can when their contracts up they
can still go out and they'll still be
famous they can keep doing their show so
go to a show somewhere else they'll be
in a far far better place you help make
them
that's the gotcha and by the way
Jeremy's also drinking his own Kool-Aid
and they're also slimy but he's also not
wrong in this case no no if you are if
you are a nobody and you want to go do a
year at the daily wire it will increase
your profile
again the gay community
a very specific Niche gay Jewish
Community yeah no not long is that this
contract this contract owns it in
perpetuity even after the contract
you're paying a lease but getting
ownership
and so this contract
but Crowders
yeah I mean again not signing it with
daily wire but
they did pay to produce it I could
understand them wanting ownership I
don't like it I would I wouldn't sign it
no no no here's the thing with that he's
framing that [__] up because [__]
by the terms of that [__] contract
they would not be paying to produce the
show they are paying a fee for the
content to be in for the to take
ownership of certain things like you
know like the the advertising and all
that [__] from certain channels
they're they are not by the terms of
that contract directly paying to produce
his Daily Show or any of that the what
he's talking about them owning is if if
you guys remember [__] in one part of
it he goes over uh a 1.25 million for
like annual Events first you covered
that yeah yeah
that 1.25 is what he's talking about so
like if we pay for the production of an
event yeah we own that
right no yeah yeah like daily wire
presents you know a college tourism then
yeah that would be their exactly
guys I don't know because right in front
of me right now there's a Crowder mug
and there's a lib I left this tear smoke
and I don't know which one to drink from
I got you papa Hulk mug thank you that's
all I want a a Hulk Hogan beat shop mug
thank you there you go that would be
cool that's better they actually had
some I'm not gonna lie when it when
taught Major Tom took me to the beach
shops I'd get Frozen the T-shirt they
had that they had nice mugs I should get
one that's a nice looks different than
producing content in the case of
breakfast check uh check locals well he
made you something oh I mean I'll talk
right now because I think I'm done with
this
oh there it is we fixed them
there it is
up for everybody give me a second we're
gonna get Chad
we are
nice Mark do it yeah do it Mark Mark
you're a mustache Man mark would look
what did I say Mark is definitely a guy
that would look would it look creepy
with a mustache you look like a Chicago
cop like a detective yeah yeah or or
honestly not that style of mustache I'd
say he should grow the Dax horror would
stash oh I yes hey Mark please do this
I'm telling you man do it it looks like
a softball coach yeah hi kids good
hustle go walk it walk it off walk it
off
one of those coaches that like actually
is just a great part of the community
yes yes yes hey Bobby don't cry you'll
get that ball next time yeah he's one of
those quotes like why'd you put my coach
you know I was in a real bad place with
drugs and like softball saved my life
just paying them forward you know God
bless just paying the floor keep your
head up you had a bad game today but hey
better at practice than during the big
day right
come on walk it off you know we're all
going Pizza Hut after this let's go
Pizza Hut I mean thanks coach dice no
problem guys I guess your peaches
delivered to practice but that's it no
more carbs till the game all right with
that said no for tonight hey hey call me
coach Mark
coach dice was my father hey come on
guys take a knee let me tell you about
the military industrial complex whoa
whoa what
and then you're like yo did you hear
that coach Mark he's [__] Mrs
Anderson I heard
remember in high school you could start
like when you started picking up on like
which parents are [__] yeah like
which teachers were banging and stuff